so I'm just gonna go with the question I
want to ask first since I have limited
time and that is do you both feel there
should be more male frontal nudity in
American cinema definitely okay well I
know you had said that with American
acting contracts that they're very
specific in terms of what body parts
will be shown
whereas in French cinema they're just
more sort of relaxed about it well you
know I it's it's true that in France
I've never signed a contract with any
details on what's kind of what was gonna
be filmed or not but it was very
interesting working in the States that
everything is so detailed and so it's I
guess it's just a different way of
working sure yeah I mean I love the idea
that the lens in this film is being
taken off of women specifically and
swung on to or you know men for a little
while I think that it's great yeah I
enjoy that I don't we don't I don't see
that quite as much I love it like no one
not us that I'm naked in this movie I
mean no one has told me oh you're naked
in this movie it's like because there's
naked man's looks like suddenly it makes
me you know be naked and okay like no
one pays attention which is good for me
okay and now back to the more
professional question and that is how
did Patrick get the script to the two of
you and what made you say yes I got a
call from mark Duplass and whose work
I'm very much a fan of and the script
was wild I mean the ending especially I
was very I was not sure how it could it
would go go but after meeting with
Patrick and talking to mark quite
extensively it seemed pretty clear that
they had a interesting vision yeah yeah
I mean Mark's also sent me the script
and I loved it I thought it was so well
rich and I was like this this writer has
a very very long you know career in
front of him and then I met the writer
who's actually the director and I was
convinced that I had to be in this movie
and you know
and I think it was right it's funny so
have either of you ever said no to a
role and why mmm yeah there have been a
few prop I mean I don't um
I feel so lucky every time I get offered
anything and I mean I feel really
fortunate for that and I think but there
it's more about when the piece is
surrounding first of all I mean it has
to be a story that's interesting but
it's it generally depends a lot on the
director and the people that would be
collaborate I'd be collaborating with
that kind of make or break whether it
works
I could really work with some people
without even reading anything you know
it's like some directors I don't care I
mean if Wes Anderson was calling me I
don't even want to read it's like you
know I to me it's really a lot about the
director of course it's also about the
script but uh it's totally about the
director right you'd mentioned that you
were all shooting at night most the time
and sometimes you were all very tired
even though you're having a great time
and it actually lent itself well to your
being inebriated in the film how do you
balance that because you're both so busy
and knowing that you have to show up on
set and and that time management and and
also refreshing yourself because I don't
imagine that would be that could take a
toll after a while that's a very
difficult I think specifically for this
movie it was hard for me just in other
areas but in general that's a tricky
thing figuring out how do I feel like
that is the question yeah yeah my kids
were like waking up when I was supposed
to get to bed I mean you know it's the
whole thing when you have kids like oh
my god I'm gonna be like the mom during
the day and work all night long
and you know people do that in their
everyday lives you know it's like it's
it's always you know you have to find a
ways
it was like exhausting but but very
interesting because not very motivating
because we loved the film and the script
well it didn't show yeah and then
whispered to each other they didn't like
with her tired are you you know because
it would be every night for 11 nights so
you could see us go like more and more
tired but we shot chronologically so it
helped yes absolutely